ils essaient la griffe on trouve ça très
sympa et ça montre le produit vraiment
de brut de chez brut souvent on peut
aussi des oc est coupée au niveau la
jointure mais nous on laisse entièrement
la griffe on trouve ça on trouve ça
assez amusant pigeonneaux de raconte le
plat par de bastien gilles et cette
spécialité d'indre-et-loire revêt une
saveur unique aux yeux du chef cuisinier
il lui attribue le fait d'avoir fait
succomber les papilles d'un inspecteur
du guide michelin
nous avons gardé le poste du michelin et
oui effectivement il y avait le label
pigeonneaux draka en photo donc on
suppose que il a eu depuis je le raconte
y avait que des produits locaux dans
l'assiette
donc je pense que c'est ça la marche je
pense que notre marque de fabrique et je
pense que c'est ça vraiment qu'il aura
plus de devoirs que bah on s'investit
pour pour les gens autour de nous qui
travaillent des produits d'exception
il y a quelques jours le chef reçoit un
coup de téléphone du directeur
international du célèbre guide surprise
de taille
l'aube est retenu par bastien et sa
femme emily obtient sa première étoile
le personnel de clients tout cas c'est
moi qui les formulent puisque c'est nos
apprentis qui sont restés chez nous et
donc bah ça valorise quand même bien
bien notre travail puisque ben voilà
c'est ils sont pas venus d'autres
maisons et pour nous c'est un c'était un
alors ont trouvé ça super que ce soit
fini comme ça c'est une fierté wilbrod
surtout même peau mais pour mes parents
des parents qui ont plongé le couple
dans le bain de la gastronomie en 2006
avec l'ouverture d'une auberge au beau
milieu de ce verger
quand nous avons démarré l'auberge c'est
mon papa qui est un ancien
arboriculteurs qui a planté tout s'est
rangé la donc là vous avez aussi vous
avez de l'abricot vous avez de la pêche
de vigne
après un apprentissage à l'aigle d'or où
il tombe amoureux
sébastien emilie viennent prêter main
forte au restaurant famille
18 20 ans on arrive dans la maison
familiale où on vient les aider parce qu
on est très famille et c'était la
logique pour nous de venir les aider
mais nous on rêvait d'aller travailler
dans les grandes maisons
sauf qu'on sait mais tellement qu'on a
eu un enfant et puis le temps a passé et
en fait ben on est resté là on n'est
jamais parti l'étoile décrocher nouveau
défi pour le couple désormais conserver
cette récompense dans la durée on n'a
plus trop le droit à l'erreur donc voilà
on va essayer de pousser la machine au
maximum
et voilà tout en restant nous-mêmes
exactement en étant en simple et en
travaillant avec des encore peut-être
plus de producteurs encore du coin et
puis à affiner notre travail au fur et à
mesure dans les années à venir
en attendant emilie et bastien compte
bien profiter encore un peu de ce rêve
qu'ils vivent éveillé